civilization and the technological
advances that have come with it I've
miraculously brought us comfort and
culture yet many of us remain unhappy
and evolutionary psychologists say that
our brains are better adapted for life
in the Stone Age
so is civilization a distortion of our
natural state leaving us discontented
are we happiest around a fire and under
the stars or is this a romantic illusion
so I'm going to ask each speaker to talk
for just three minutes on their opening
thoughts on this and whether we're
better suited to life in the Stone Age
I'll start with a quote which I'm sure
you
known is probably a pick apocryphal from
Gandhi who was asked what do you think
of Western civilization and allegedly
said I think it would be a good idea and
then roughly is is the way things are
civilizations like one of those big
things like sort of socialism and
science and religion which ought to be a
fabulous idea automated transformer
lives very much for the better and the
thing it does I think more than anything
else a single thing it does is to enable
us to live in very big groups and living
in very big groups means that we
couldn't specialize at all that kind of
stuff so you can have special engineers
and special teachers and even have
writers of books that's and that's what
you know you've arrived very fabulous it
ought to be liberating however there are
some very very big snags one is a
psychology I mean I refer you to Robin
Dunbar of Oxford who said it's very
difficult for human beings to live in
groups of bigger than 150 because you
can't recognize many people bigger than
that going with a corollary of that is
that when you have big groups you they
need to be organized otherwise they
become chaotic so you have a bureaucracy
arising which automatically means you
get some kind of a oppression coming on
you get the rise of technology which
ought to be a good thing but in fact it
is the way things are or the way things
have always been technology could just
as easily be an agent of oppression as
it can of liberation and then you have
you put point I was gonna make now but
if you put two things together the
organization on the one hand which tends
to be reduced to an algorithm in other
words you remove human judgment and you
replace it with some kind of universal
formula which is what's happened at the
economy where you know we now have
neoliberalism the point not being that
it is capitalist but the point being
that is an algorithm we just rely on the
market to run our affairs a terrible
state of affairs and we have technology
of the kind which has led us to a kind
of techno philia any new technology must
be good we have now have the combination
of neoliberalism and
no philia which you see in governments
which you see in the Royal Society which
you see in everybody in serious
positions of authority and to my mind
actually it's demonstrable we're not
gonna talk about it here
I think this techno philia stoked
neoliberalism it's probably the greatest
threat to humankind enter the biosphere
that one can envisage actually it's much
more dangerous than Isis for example
although we're on red alert 2 1 and
we're invited to vote for the other so
that's where civilization is where it's
always been
could be a good thing actually highly
equivocal
I think one way to view civilization is
of attaining a state where we have
managed to kind of effectively take care
of on those basic needs so we're not
worried about being swooped upon by
predators we have enough to eat we don't
have to worry too much about where our
next meal is coming from we have
somewhere to shelter from bad weather
and so on so we cope we don't have to
worry about the sort of life-or-death
things and having fulfilled those needs
we're then in a state where we can
alongside other people work towards
fulfilling other needs that aren't
essential such as the need for culture
and so on now technology comes in in a
way that can help us do that but I agree
that we're not always very good at doing
it so technology enables us to fulfill
not only our most basic needs but also
the desires and needs that we have
beyond that so a need for nice clothes
and so on and I need for food that
doesn't just nourish us but which also
tastes nice and so on so technology
enables us to do these things we're not
always very good at using technology so
that was there was a point that that Joe
made towards the beginning that a lot of
people are a lot of people are miserable
and part of that might be to do with
this point about about psychology we we
have certain needs and we're not always
sure how to meet them and one problem
might be that we are focusing too much
on the wrong sorts of things so we focus
on some short-term needs we focus on
sort of demands of the market so Adam
and for Adam antiphon sort of find out
what celebrities are wearing and for
sort of frivolous frivolous products as
a consumerist mindset where we sort of
buy things they make up those makers
temporarily happy and then we dispose of
them and while we're doing that we're
actually ignoring multiple pressing
problems and one of the reasons that we
might be ignoring them is because of
this Stone Age psychology so in the
Stone Age when we lived in sort of
fairly small communities we had to deal
with the problems that did arose for
those
communities were on a fairly small scale
especially morale problems if somebody
did something bad it affected that it
had quite a local effect but now we're
having to deal with global problems and
one of the reasons we have to deal with
global problems is that we have
technology which enables us to have
far-reaching effects so some of the most
pressing problems today are things like
climate change that we have to sort of
work together you know sort of all the
country have to work together to find a
solution we have to cooperate with each
other to solve the the problem of you
know the crisis in Syria to accommodate
all the refugees all the sort of country
should be working together finding out
the best solution but instead everyone
sort of still behaving quite selfishly
we don't all sort of cooperate with each
other
to to reduce our carbon emissions and so
on or to sort of cooperate and find
homes for refugees and one of the
reasons is that we're still sort of
quite selfish we're thinking of sort of
what what effect this will have on all
sort of fairly local communities and if
everybody thinks in that way then we're
not going to be able to sort of solve
these problems that require sort of
action and cooperation on the global
scale so technology isn't necessarily
working to help us find these solutions
that we need to these these big problems
but it could do and one of the
professional things that's discussed
amongst my philosopher colleagues is the
idea of moral enhancement and this is
the idea that our psychology is sort of
set up to deal with moral problems on a
fairly small scale and we just can't
deal with these big problems I want we
to change that might be through the use
of technology so there are some reasons
to think that things like cooperation
and Trust things that are needed for
sort of action on a on a large scale
might rely on sort of biological factors
that we can change through things like
drugs any drugs that around now
necessarily but in the future so we
might be able to enhance ourselves to
become better moral decision-makers now
this could possibly be of use to
everybody I mean it's always useful to
be better at practical reasoning but one
thing that could be really useful for is
to morally enhance our politicians so
that they kind of make make more moral
decisions now if that were the case if
we could do that then I don't think
anybody could persuasively argue that
technology is wholly
bad
well you know we're stuck I mean we took
the red pill you know there's no I
there's no going back I think is the
best way to look at it I okay something
completely at random I one of my side
gigs is to I work in the videogame field
developing video games and this means
that I have to play a certain amount of
video games I have to I have to
it's a professional requirement and I've
been playing one recently I don't know
if anyone else has played I'm looking at
the audience I'm doubting many people
called Far Cry primal no no takers yeah
oh good excellent awesome game right
yeah it's a great game and it takes
place a bit supposedly takes place you
know myth the mythological land of auto
switch resemble central Europe more or
less more or less ten thousand years ago
and although it makes no attempt to
pretend it's actually you know based in
the history that we know of that period
which in itself is limited it has a sort
of it has a stab at giving you some
sense of what it might have been like to
live back then it's very beautiful and
you do you know in between times you
kind of go to sleep and wake up by this
little campfire in beautiful environment
and there's this great sense of
belonging because you belong to a tribe
that you've got to help build up and so
forth um but yeah you walk out of the
camp and take a wrong turn and you're
you'll be eaten by a saber-toothed tiger
even more impactful from my point of
view as as you know looking at game
design and storytelling in games if you
meet another human being you pretty much
shoot them dead with an arrow because if
you don't the chances are they'll shoot
you and and you're basically after a
while you discover there were some other
tribes hanging out and these other
tribes I've got the same interests that
you have which are to maximize their
tribal benefits and and you do you live
basically hand-to-mouth and you live a
life of if it weren't a game of Terror
because you are terrified all the time
of being killed and most the most
threatening thing is is not the wildlife
it is the other humans because they're
smarter than the animals